welcome to this video 0 moral yeah this
is a okay three games thought I played
him more often the other exchange
version of the Royal this is not a super
exciting line i'm trying to make it
exciting with some sideline hmm yeah
Queen to d4 I am I would like to Castle
long really but if I do that he probably
will go Queen ASA wanna play Bishop g4
maybe yeah I can maybe irritate him a
bit with this idea okay so much for
irritation he's not reacting to it at
all yeah I can try to take you ok let's
take and go from there I a long castle
it's not possible due to rule rule
restrictions hmm ok just cam
Luke d8 Queen a 7 hmm that's not really
good Queen d7 is Queenie five I thought
of I should have thought about that a
little bit more this capture on f3 it's
really a slightly slightly annoying
position
Jim I don't really know how to play that
thinking maybe night h5 is helping me
okay at least his misplacing his night
him I hope this size helping me a bit
questioner yeah the night is totally
wrong here quite obviously but ok I'm
getting rid of this that's good and now
we can he even allows me to trade Queens
interesting ok yeah so this should be
fine now Bishop t4 yeah this is helpful
ok
I interesting i can i can also castle
long what taking its both both okay here
chan well the group t3 I can still take
it is just equal men chanting nothing
much else
now I actually think that my position is
somewhat easier to play due to the to
the default but it's still nothing
special wyd can push what okay yeah this
is of course just a bad moon will see
for it gives me it gives me ideas here
okay so see for our Kings is 60 both
quite good let's check mate um quite
deservedly if I don't really know why
you need to play all this instantly
white was already and somewhat worse of
course not not so bad that she should
get mated he should play e5 him and then
I go see form and I have to someone more
dangerous position here he should he
shouldn't lose but it's um it was a step
by step step concession c4s is just
terrible I mean giving giving up this
square and allowing me this b5 play um
he had a pretty good position here I
think at night Jeff 693 SS is not really
really helping him night age five and
now he has to go Bishop b3 this is this
is just giving up any hope of an
advantage I rook t8 was maybe even
stronger here yeah it was stronger of
course yeah this was even better because
well where is he going the Queen c5 move
is a really annoying thing to happen I
mean something like that for example
yeah
it gets really ugly and squid yeah okay
this is just just equal now but yeah
yeah he conceded lots of things step by
step and SCLC forgives black like the
advantage and this is a funny funny
self-made yeah even even this is a mate
nice let's take some effort okay well
thanks for watching